today was the final round of the 2014
st. Louis Invitational an event that was
the most fruitful of its kind in the
Chess Club and scholastic center of st.
Louis's history three players left st.
Louis very happy Semyon completed his
climb to six and a half points with a
final round draw against Raja Panjwaii I
want to say thanks to the organizers and
for organizing this tournament and it's
really hard for Nome stickers to play in
the US we have to go overseas and it's
really nice he didn't really know what
to do I mean he was thinking of play e5
or 30 of f6 to gain some space but I
think after just 20 to fall by 92 94
then this d6 squares a bit weak one of
my Knights can enter there so he didn't
want that talking about age 6 now I just
played Bishop d2 if he does nothing
probably I'll play Knight e5 or rook d1
again
Bishop c1 d4 so he played B 586 b5 maybe
95 90 X 90 97 about 97 because if he
goes night after 6th and I play in 96
which is a 4 and he'll have to give away
his LightSquared Bishop it's a bit
better because I have two bishops and if
he plays f6 wicked if he can't play up 6
here because of g6 is hanging but just a
nice idea would be 96 Bishop takes Queen
e6 and so forth
lady 7 now exchange these bishops
technically I'm probably a bit worse but
because of this week d3 prom but it
should be hold upon 24 25 I was looking
at Rugby 6 with the idea of Brooke g6 to
hit this d3 pawn and I was looking at
the liner k7 route d6 and Bishop f4 now
one point Knight takes f7 and Bishop
takes d6 so FG v 9 takes f7 rook takes
Bishop this here I can play Brigade
Bishop d6 and I think what's a bit
better and the main point I think is a
roopd 5 and I have rook takes e7 didn't
take c7 Knight takes c6 which is a fork
and I have this poof and it's a pin so I
went upon he played 25 exchange of
Queens but now I think I'm fine okay 6 I
want to play rook c6 so he stopped it
with rook c8 and I mean I don't think
either side can progress yourself we
made some moves King G to h5 bishops 196
if c4 I take take Rho K 4 and C 4 is
really weak so if I died b6 h 4 I could
sacrifice my knife but Knight takes c6
and get three pawns but I think that my
pawns aren't too advanced and then I
don't have the chances of holding this
position after 87 or maybe Ruby 8 and d3
is really weak and the happen move like
56 you can trade in played before and
try to win upon the consensus so I put
age 40 by Brigade only funny
professional was if he plays rugby a
knight c6 rook takes d3 up night a5 it
would be 896 on his draw if he tries to
avoid
Perpetual with prove g6 95 d7 since now
he is defending and I'd with this regard
Bishop a4 deflection
so I played with gay but now after a
night of threes just people I'm gonna
develop my final piece that's it before
if Knight b6 then I simply play Bishop
III and I betrayed him why it's fun
before I played Bishop III here if he
decides to take on c3 twice then I
thought rook c1 attacking his bishop and
if he pins majors defend my Bishop and
that's it four versus four is drop
Bishop f8 95-96 now I just traded into a
drum position your honor pending I could
play a move like rook a 1 here or I
could play on the previous 4 ok 1 but I
think after BC BC 97 it's gonna be
really hard to win this positions just
to equal after 95 96 I just traded into
a rock ending and here he offered me a
draw because I mean after I capture I
attack this pawn you'll take this I'll
take that it's just 4 versus 4 instead
of 13 year-old samsa beyond earned his
second Grand Master norm as well Kaden
troph left st. Louis with a rating over
2500 securing his spot as a bona fide
Grandmaster in the top tournament Grand
Master been Feingold finished a
middle-of-the-road it was still good
enough to earn him some money however
and he was impressed with some of the
players in this tournament there South
Holman was very impressive I also
thought Rob Burnett played pretty well
South home I got seven out of nine and
he was my student about eight years ago
and we worked for a couple years
together so that was pretty happy about
that
and Seth played really well so that's
really solid when is Seth with three
rounds to go what do you need for a norm
he said I don't know he just wanted to
play chess and he's just trying to play
well and he said he seeded the norm by
half a point so he was the most
impressive in the B group in our second
tournament even though he only needed a
draw to get his norm
feed a master Seth Houma made sure he
got the win in his game against Levon
Braganza
to reach seven point I have like zero
expectations going into this one because
I just came off the Chicago open so I
spent the entire day in between events
driving down here I also caught a cold
halfway through like apparently
everybody else in the speedo did and so
having zero expectations actually helped
me like settle down and relax and just
like take one game at a time and try to
play the best movie to move to Queen of
five I think isn't doing this entire
game he was playing pretty quickly
because he might have pressed me on the
clock as well as on the board but I
can't help but feel like I got a really
comfortable position in the early middle
game here and he tries to mix things up
at a five but I don't know whether that
was I don't know whether that's like
best or not but after B 5 I was not
expecting D 5 at all and now I was
getting just a little bit worried
because if I play something like he
takes d5 then he gets like these two
connected passers on the queenside after
eight seven drops I've tried d4 takes
things like this I did not like think
maybe you know you can even just snap
off on a seven pretty mean past a pawn
here other options I sort of looked at
95 I wasn't sure what was going on after
94 briefly looked in 97 before he looked
at Nightbeat aid but taking on c4 seemed
critical it takes to stay sutures
maybe White's pay can be improved upon
he was still moving quickly which
surprised me because I thought it was
kind of critical rook takes c6 167 and
92 I thought I was pretty much okay here
I thought maybe you should have taken
some more time on the previous moves
because I thought that those are
critical positions because well this
past eight Pollux really really scary
not my pest be pawn has some protection
and there are some problems on the back
ring for white
work fd1 work cd6 now I have nasty
threats of Nigeria check50 c1 and this
might have been the decisive error
because after Queen f6 now I'm
threatening b2 and there's like no way
for him to get out of it really I looked
at lines like there should be 6 b2 Queen
takes d6 but I can just take in the
corner here that's winning for white for
backside what were some other moves here
rook do you 1k was tonight f3 more back
bring stuff if Queen takes to b6
this is nothing I can block work d8 that
was important to see so he paid Ricky 1
but I'm just winning up to be 2
he pays um or p1 I could just grab back
ring checkmate yeah the 4 KD 1 I just
played a knight after you check in
everything's crumbling here so if it
takes then I could take d1 and not only
just white da materia but I'm gonna
Queen also so this is pretty much pretty
much over for white after his last game
Seth remarks that he did better in this
tournament than all of his other st.
Louis Norma vents combined and he earned
it clear first in this tournament and
the winner of a second international
master nor the 2014 st. Louis
Invitational was by far the most
fruitful of its kind that we've had here
in terms of norms achieved and goals
achieved and we hope you join us again
in another six months when we do it all
again for the Chess Club and scholastic
center of st. Louis I'm Ben Simon